la guerra en Ucrania ha llegado hasta
esta mansión en las afueras de Ginebra
en su interior decenas de personas de la
Cruz Roja ruso ucraniano parlantes
trabajan a contrarreloj su misión es
ayudar a localizar y determinar el
paradero de prisioneros de guerra y
otros desaparecidos del conflicto
lo primero y más importante es que las
familias conozcan las fuertes de sus
seres queridos Esta es a menudo una de
las partes y cicatrices menos visibles
de la guerra pero es importante que las
familias sepan esto en medio de un
conflicto armado violento
esta Agencia Central de búsqueda de la
Cruz Roja gestiona unas 900 consultas al
día y desde marzo ha podido proporcionar
información sobre sus seres queridos a
más de 3.000 familias un trabajo con
alta carga emocional
la parte invisible de este trabajo
básicamente Escuchar porque muy a menudo
las familias llaman están desesperadas
están angustiadas y lo que hacemos muy a
menudo Es simplemente Escuchar estar
presentes
no siempre transmiten buenas noticias a
las familias motivo por el que cada
prueba de paradero o vida es un gran
logro para toda la oficina
solo saber que la madre tendrá noticias
de su hijo hoy y sabrá que está vivo es
algo que nos produce una inmensa
absolutamente inmensa satisfacción
un servicio que será fundamental para
los familiares de desaparecidos hasta el
final de esta guerra